so this sort of profound difference and
it is to me very profound
why can't we when we're training as a
student
they have the same
head on me
as a teacher why can't I just try in why
do I have to prove anything why do I
have to
aim to
let's get it right and by endurance
doing so I get it so badly wrong
oh I couldn't do anything with them
people and I was really trying
I kept adjusting I kept doing things
and yet you go back home I used to find
I would go back home to my club let's
say eight you know a top Scentsy
Japanese or european Western it doesn't
matter
but these top senses would be teaching
the glass
we would bow quickly find a partner
train
and have all these struggles or all this
pleasure that I was telling you about so
we've got ego or we've got sadness
that's not sadness but you know not as
satisfied as we'd like to be
or we'd get great joy because we'd be
doing it
but a lot of the teachers I followed
were doing much more flowing Stars
because that seems to be in a lot
wider
Acceptance in the world than the
awamaroo that that I finally chose
is much more
static
much more technical
can be boring to some I I haven't found
it so but maybe boring some because it's
not constant flowing aerobic
cardiovascular Aikido being performed is
looking more about finer detail as I was
saying earlier about the hand and the
thumb being everything working together
everything working at the correct time
same time
unifying everything
it's more about flowering keeping their
partner going you flowing until the the
end of the throw and making it look
beautiful and dynamic
but even with all this flow and me being
perhaps stiff minded thinking oh they're
missing out so much on the technical
perhaps hindering my advancement because
being stubborn and wanting to criticize
even if in my mind and yet going along
being good okay running around taking
the ukami and then went throwing them I
have to copy the flowing style I can't
do my own bike or my own style
so this is
um the message that I've tried to give
you in this film
is do you
have the same problems
are you a teacher when you teach and you
teach with confidence because that's
what the class expects that's what the
students expect that's what
is expected from a teacher not to say oh
dear I don't know if I can do that no I
might struggle with you about pick
somebody a little bit weak and lighter
because you look a bit strong and you
might make me look bad
yes these things may have gone through
your mind and you may feel guilty now
talking about it about yes I've done
that and I've had to pick somebody I
felt confident I could show it on
because they may look made me look bad
and I might not be able to do it and
that means then I might not be able to
keep teaching or I might not be invited
back if I choose somebody out of the
audience of students
that I don't know they might not go
where I want them to go so yeah because
you know because I need I need to be
invited back I need to be liked
I bet I can't safe and sound
play play my cards will say the right
way the right hand
yes even though I'm big I might be
losing confidence in oh he's a big guy
or she looks a bit too small I might
have been my knees too much no I better
not choose to have this technique but I
can choose it for the flowering
technique where I'm going to look
beautiful and lovely
yeah
so even with this hat on
we can lack confidence
and one day hopefully if you all travel
long enough in your Aikido
if you're all
think about these things
humble yourself be honest with yourself
this cat
will stay in the brand new condition
that it is today
because you won't need it
you won't need to
experience that
you'll be able to be happy
with what do they say the skin that
you're in
you know that you'll have problems from
time to time because we're human beings
so my message to you is
try to
be a teacher even if you're not saying
anything
while training with other people
not the teacher that teaches the class
who teaches the seminar you will have
the confidence you'll go home and you
will think about your
your class whether it was good or bad
and you will perhaps try to polish
yourself
that will be between you and you
if you've got a best friend you might
say to them didn't have a great class
last night or you might say oh I had a
really good class like that last night
and that reward will be more than just
Technical and you got it right it will
because you had a warmth inside
you had a feeling of compassion and you
had a feeling of
knowing that your senses and their
senses became one
and you become
or howling complete